- From 1925 to 2014 the
United States corn yield,
measured in bushels per
acre, bushels per acre,
grew by approximately 2.41% per year.
By contrast, during the same time period,
soybean yield grew by approximately 3.5
bushels per acre every 10 years.
Alright, so there's something
interesting going on here.
They've given us how
much the corn yield grows
in percentage terms, on a
per year percentage terms.
While for soybeans yield they
tell us how much it grows
in absolute terms, 3.5 bushels
per acre every 10 years.
I guess you could say on average
0.35, if you divide by 10
0.35 bushels per acre per year.
A NASS survey showed that in 1959
the corn yield was,
actually let me make a little table here.
I'm already sensing this'll be useful.
So, let's think about this.
So, we're gonna say, so
an NASS survey showed that
in 1959 the corn yield was
51.2 bushels per acre.
So, this is gonna be corn,
then they talk about soybean
a little bit so soybean.
So, in 1959.
In 1959 the corn yield
was, so we're gonna assume
everything's in bushels per
acre, 51.2 bushels per acre
and the soybean yield was
23.5 bushels per acre.
Based on the information
above which of the following
is the best estimate for
the difference between
the corn yield and the
soybean yield in 1974?
So, 1974, so how many years have gone by?
Let's see this is going to be 15 years.
So, this is gonna be +15 years
from our 1959.
So, actually the soybean is a
little bit easier to calculate
'cause they just tell us the
absolute number of bushels
per acre every 10 years.
So, 15 years, if you do 3.5
bushels per acre every 10 years,
well 15 years is just gonna
be half more of that again.
So, this is just gonna be 23.5
so in 10 years it'll grow
by 3.5 bushels per acre,
that's what they tell us.
And then in another 5 years
it'll grow by half of this.
Half of 10 years, well this
is gonna grow by let's see,
half of 3.5 is what?
It is 1.75, and so
what is that going to be?
Let's see 23.5+3.5 gets us to
27, then 27
+1.75 is 28.75
bushels per acre in 1974.
Did I do that right?
23.5+3.5 is gonna be 27,
28.75, yep.
So, if we grow 3.5 bushels
per acre in 10 years
we're gonna grow 1.75 bushels per acre in
the next 5 years so that's the 15 years.
Right over here this is
10 years plus 5 years,
so we get to 28.75.
Now corn, what's corn going to be?
Well, here we're going by
a percentage every year.
So, this is going to be
51.2 and we are growing,
we're going to multiply this times
1.0241.
If you're growing by 2.41
percent that's the equivalent
of multiplying by 1.0241.
You grow, you keep what you have
and add 2.41% right over here.
And, you're going to multiply
that by as many years
as you have, so it's going
to be to the 15th power.
Well, I don't know what
1.0241 to the 15th power is
but luckily this is one of the
questions where a calculator
is encouraged, so let's figure this out.
So, let's figure out, let me
make sure it's all cleared out.
1.0241
and let me raise it to the 15th power
is equal to 1.42 all of this business
and then multiply that by 51.2.
So, times 51.2 is equal to
73. roughly 73.18.
So, this is approximately 73.18.
Now what they want is
what's the best estimate
for the difference between the corn yield
and the soybean yield.
So, the difference 73.18 minus 28.75
and they have a couple
choices that are kinda close
so let me just make sure
I do the math right.
I can do this on paper
but we have our calculator
so I'll just use that.
So, minus 28.75
to calculate the difference
gets us to about 44.4
and if we're gonna round
to the nearest whole it be 44.
So, it's this choice, that
choice right over there.